- We're going to kick the show off with
a white British man doing a freestyle rap.
So everyone here think of a
word or a topic or a phrase
you'd like to hear a rap about.
There are some rules.
Don't suggest food or animals.
It's too boring.
Don't suggest anything too obvious.
Don't say anything that I've mentioned.
Don't be like, "oh, the queen."
And be creative. Be imaginative.
Try and challenge me.
What would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Jaden Smith.
- Jaden Smith? Cool, do you know him?
- Yeah. No I don't know I don't know him.
- Why did you lie?
That's was, that's cool. Cool.
It's weird cause you looked at,
I think maybe I'm trying to think of
how you made that connection.
You've probably looked at me.
You were like, he's a white rapper.
Will Smith, essentially
a white rapper innit he?
He's a bit corny.
Okay. Jaden Smith, Jaden Smith,
if you don't know, is the son
of Will and Jada Pinkett Smith
and, and he's, you know, he's in the
ASAP Rocky potato salad
video in the background.
He's a handsome guy.
He took a, uh, he took
a picture of himself
as his date to the Met
Gala a few years ago.
That's fun.
Cool.
Tampa, what would you like to rap about?
The education system in
Florida isn't very good.
Not quick off the mark.
Yeah, but no, no, you can,
you can give me your favorite fruit.
We'll rap about your
favorite fruit. That's fun.
- [Tampa Audience Member] Peaches.
- Peaches. I dunno.
No, that's cool.
Just Florida has, Florida is oranges.
Georgia's peaches, isn't it?
You're not like state represent,
like I only eat oranges.
No, peaches. Okay.
So peaches, Jaden Smith.
That's come to my Welsh
man by way of Notting Hill,
What would you like to rap about?
- [Welsh Audience Member]
Let's go flux capacitor.
- Flux, capacitor.
He has a lovely accent.
I can't do a Welsh accent.
So when I do a Welsh accent,
it kind of strays into Indian.
Very offensive.
[Laughter]
Oh the lovely valleys with the daffodils.
Great, so flux capacitor.
Which if you don't know, Tampa,
that's from the movie Back to the Future.
Right, front row.
Hey, what would you like a rap up about?
Ooh you're pointing,
you're like the boss here.
Everyone was just pointing at you.
Just like, he knows.
- [Audience Member] Socialized Healthcare.
- Socialized Healthcare. Cool.
Are you involved in that? Is
that part of like your job?
- [Audience Member] I'm uninsured.
- You're uninsured. So you're
like, please demand it.
Okay. That's cool.
Socialized health, good, it's very-
Uninsured, it's good that
you're wearing such short shorts
to get all that vitamin D
You know, that's what you want.
Just get every little
square inch of skin.
So Socialized Healthcare, Flux Capacitor,
Peaches, and the Jaden Smith.
Two single ladies who were sat together,
what would you like a rap up about?
- [Audience Member] Pocket Pussy.
- Pocket Pussy? Okay.
Yeah.
Is that that's, the in the UK
they're called fleshlights,
right? That's it's like,
- [Audience Member] Guys put
their dick in it and pretend
like it's a vagina.
- Yeah, in the UK it's-
- [Audience Member] I
was at a bar last night,
and people were selling
them on the orders.
- Really?
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
- Where's the bar?
- [Audience Member] What?
[Laughter]
- Okay. I was going to come to you guys,
but I think pocket pussy has talked us out
as a great suggestion.
So a pocket pussy, socialized healthcare,
flux capacitor, Jaden Smith, and peaches.
This is going to be a freestyle.
That's a rap made up on the spot based
on telling their suggestions.
And do not worry.
It's not going to be anywhere near as
atrociously, embarassingly, tokenly bad
as you're expecting it to be.
Let's drop that beat.
Let's have a little chuckle,
have a little bit of fun.
and you can turn up a
little bit as well, Matthew.
That's a nice, that feels good.
It drops in with the base.
It's going to be, it's quite chill.
I chose a nice chill one.
♪ Yeah, we got suggestions. ♪
♪ You given me the answer. ♪
♪ The nice fruit ♪
♪ understand tha man from Tampa ♪
♪ Within reach go down
Georgia for the peach ♪
♪ with a nice supple orange, ♪
♪ like the sand on a beach, ♪
♪ I can see that. ♪
♪ Oh, I tell you the truth. ♪
♪ Let me get my own plate, ♪
♪ and I'm licking up the juice, ♪
♪ It's amazing ♪
♪ the little sucrose, the sugar ♪
♪ I'd get my tongue,
better than any other, ♪
♪ have you seen the movie,
Call Me by Your Name? ♪
♪ They stick the fuckin'
the peach in the scene, ♪
♪ it's a shame. ♪
♪ Yeah, Timothée Chalamet
and Armie Hammer, ♪
♪ They grabbed the peach, then
they just start to slam a ♪
♪ pair a little fingers in there. ♪
♪ They ain't foresee, disagree. ♪
♪ Motion when you workin' on the pussy ♪
♪ you can go up and down
that don't drop it. ♪
♪ I'm talking about the pussy
that I store in my pocket. ♪
♪ It's right in the front.
That's the cum that I move, ♪
♪ maybe get it going motion ♪
♪ when I'm adding up the lube, ♪
♪ with the motion that I cause. ♪
♪ Went down to the bar, ♪
♪ a guy's on the corner, ♪
♪ like a little bizarre,
or maybe market stall ♪
♪ He's shoutin' out "Pocket Pussy!" ♪
♪ I'm like, have you got the sizes? ♪
♪ He's like, yo, ♪
♪ I've got the large, medium and small. ♪
♪ And I'm like to have the extra small, ♪
♪ because I liked the pussy tight. ♪
♪ He says "whoa, Chris,
this pussy underage" ♪
♪ I'm like, shit, I shouldn't
mention this shit on stage. ♪
♪ The pocket pussy, you know we like. ♪
♪ Moving over here, Yeah. Shape of a Y, ♪
♪ not the letter from the alphabet, ♪
♪ but the thing that
gets you back in time ♪
♪ Seein' Doc Brown and Marty McFly ♪
♪ and their damn minds. ♪
♪ They was so crazy. ♪
♪ Get in the DeLorean, ♪
♪ if you've never seen the movie, ♪
♪ the shit will be boring but it's fine. ♪
♪ Made by the GMC, ♪
♪ the general motors corporation. ♪
♪ You can even see it 1, 2, 3, ♪
♪ the third's in the wild west. ♪
♪ Need to get the flux capacitor, ♪
♪ better than the rest. ♪
♪ I think they dealt with
the Libyan's nuclear power. ♪
♪ And let me talk about
Jaden Smith for two hours. ♪
♪ Well, I know very little facts, ♪
♪ other than his parents are black. ♪
♪ And he's lookin pretty fly ♪
[Laughter]
♪ when he's comin' over here ♪
♪ And he was like, "I wanna
try to do a fly rap career" ♪
♪ Did it take off? ♪
♪ Nah, nobody's aware. ♪
♪ They don't know what he does, ♪
♪ But the healthcare ♪
♪ he doesn't pay for it, ♪
♪ he's probably got it on his parents, ♪
♪ cause they're rich,
but you're like, nah, ♪
♪ they should share it. ♪
♪ Pay their fair share of tax,
and then you'd be insured and ♪
♪ you could just relax. ♪
♪ But the sadly, now you're like, ♪
♪ oh shit, I really gotta miss
my next doctor's appointment. ♪
♪ The Dermatologist
can't look at any moles ♪
♪ or any skin tags. ♪
♪ We need to put Republicans
in some bin bags. ♪
♪ That's a trash bag. ♪
♪ But the whole phrase rhymed ♪
♪ Bernie Sanders stands
up for ya this time. ♪
♪ He was like, yeah, we
want that health care. ♪
♪ Don't alarm you. It won't harm you. ♪
♪ The healthcare from Obama, but still, ♪
♪ you only get it if you've
got a little bit of money, ♪
♪ if you own it too much, ♪
♪ they looking at you funny. ♪
♪ Still healthcare is good. ♪
♪ Don't push me. And just be careful, ♪
♪ don't get your cock stuck in a pussy. ♪
[Laughter]
[Applause]